what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to
many men um
frito bang
featuring j da young gan before i start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos also i'm selling sweatshirts now
um feel free to cop one
um the link is in my bio
okay let's let's go
we got a strong head node
[Music]
[Music]
bruce wayne propane hit him with that
five just like do man
okay so he mentioned propane
i don't know what he's using the propane
for i didn't think i really got it but
he did he did mention some propane
[Music]
man
[Music]
i put him through a [ __ ] chest and tell
them fished up i keep this [ __ ] up on
my side just put my dick up a [ __ ] see
me they know it's murder but they had a
sticker you trying to get that [ __ ] in
blood you better not pick us
okay so if someone says
if you're trying to get that in blood
right
that means that
like they're trying to kill you like if
you
get your stuff or whatever like you'll
be dead yeah like don't he's saying like
don't try me basically
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um so he mentioned praying i thought
that was good you know
praying is good
um i don't know what he's saying spin
the bends drop a 10.
are we going
what are we spending ten dollars on did
you get a bargain is he like talking
about a
bargain in this [ __ ]
[Music]
okay i didn't understand half of that
but the part i did understand he is
saying even if he moved moves to the
suburbs like
like there's the cops
or no the ops are gonna be getting no
sleep so we say i'm like i'm gonna be a
menace even if i'm in the suburbs
i understand if you want to move to the
suburbs to be honest the suburbs are
fire i love the suburbs
with these ears drop a 10 drop a 10.
drop a time i just want to know what are
we dropping 10 on
um
okay
a lot of
oh he's flipping off the camera that's
not nice
um okay
that
that song i didn't really understand a
lot so i'm gonna have to give that
like a two out of five to be honest
because i really did not know what was
going on like i didn't understand half
of the things they were talking about
but let me know in the comments if you
guys enjoyed that
and don't forget to subscribe
by my merch
bye